[Musique]
les banques canadiennes symbole de
stabilité dans le monde entier depuis la
crise immobilière et après dix ans parce
qu'elle était bien réglementé se trouve
donc ébranlé maintenant par un scandale
mais à jour par les révélations anonyme
de plusieurs dizaines d'employés dans
près de 1000 courriels des employés de
la banque royale de la banque mondiale
de la banque cibc la banque td et de la
banque scotia de partout dans copé y
décrivent les pressions qu'ils ont subis
ou qu'ils subissent encore pour
atteindre des cibles et ils disent que
leur travail est surveillé toutes les
semaines tous les jours voire dans
certains cas toutes les heures alors que
la commissaire de lagence de la
consommation en matière financière du
canada
lucie tedesco annonce la tenue d'une
enquête et rappelle que le respect des
règles par les institutions financières
n'est pas discrétionnaire beaucoup de
canadiens se demandent eux comment on en
était arrivé à un tel dérapage
il s'agit de faire des profits
rapidement de gonfler les ventes pour
maintenir la job et des gens qui sont
dans ce domaine là et ce sont des
patriotes qui sont pas permises dans la
loi théoriquement on doit avoir comme
intérêt l'intérêt du client et ce qu'on
voit le dénoncer par la subissent
illacais de l'asub ici c'est que les
employés ils vont au delà de 2012 et
président de modhac au québec
il s'agit du mouvement d'éducation et de
la défense des actionnaires le
consommateur l'épargnant est pas
nécessairement maître de ses destinées
lauréat sera reconnaissant financière
par qui la connaît pas les tenants et
aboutissants part qu'il est pour former
aux engage de ces substances à l'aide de
ses conseillers et que souvent il prend
pas le temps d'aller s'informer spécial
vin de ce qu'on lui offre
et de ce qu'on veut lui vende compris
financiers et ça c'était un grand défaut
là je pense à travers le canada
il n'y a pas beaucoup de gens qui
s'informent qui prennent le temps
comptera à l'achat d'un véhicule par
exemple où il peut prendre des jours les
destins de ces fonds
mais regardez celui d'ahmed comment les
différents produits qui sont à faire
pour les produits financiers
c'est pas le cas et les consommateurs
sont à la merci des vendeurs les
commentaires recueillis depuis deux
semaines par 6 bis si le service de
nouvelles donc anglophone de
radio-canada semble sans équivoque le
dire un conseiller financier de la
banque scotia
ils veulent qu'on atteigne nos cibles
peu importe la méthode
un employé de la banque cbc raconte on
attend de moi que je vante de façon
persuasive des produits spécialement de
la carte visa que j'atteigne des cibles
peu importe si ça nous aux clients
l'afer est devenu politique
le npd parti d'opposition important au
parlement canadien dénonce les pratiques
douteuses des banques chaque arrêt sur
les élections fédérales alors oui le
clan mort rôle à jouer
c'est un livre demain les taux ne peut
pas tenir la main de tout un chacun ici
quelqu'un train des mauvaises décisions
et âcre et en signant des cartes de
crédit qui ont des taux d'intérêt vers
ma trop élevé à l'oeil n pas de réponse
réputés et des visuels enceinte à
alexandre boulerice et député du comté
rosemont la petite patrie à montréal au
québec et porte parole du nouveau parti
démocratique en matière des finances
enfin toujours que le secteur financier
que nos banques restent des clients les
consommateurs respecte la loi également
mais là ça se multiplient des centaines
d'employés qui viennent témoigner qu'il
doit qu'ils subissent la pression qu'ils
doivent parfois faire accepter ou vendre
à des clients des produits financiers
qui ne sont pas dans l'intérêt du
consommateur mais dans les dents seuls
intérêts de la banque et des profits
faramineux qu'ils font à chaque année
c'est extrêmement troublant ce que vos
collègues ont découvert alors moi il
était très heureux d'apprendre que l'
agence la consommation en matière
financière du canada allait ouvrir une
enquête mois d'avril le mois prochain
mais nous avait dit on voit également
demandé que comité des finances tant sur
la question
je pense que les deux peuvent aller de
pair de manière parallèle des aides
complémentaires de quelle agence bon
sens on ressent son étude nous l'a bien
devant les conclusions ne sera que vous
êtes rendu public le plus rapidement
possible on avait peur que le
gouvernement trudeau va accepter qu'il
ya une étude du groupe parlementaire
également là dessus on pourrait alors ce
moment leur faire venir des employés ou
des anciens employés détergents des
banques pour venir témoigner
et voir s'il ya matière à changer les
lois existantes pour améliorer la
protection des consommateurs que les
banques soient peut-être plus éthique
est en soi mais on n'est jamais très
inquiet on venait d'apprendre cette
semaine également que le taux
d'endettement personnel est à terre un
record auquel à 267 pour fins de revenus
donc il faut âgées l'enquète sur les
pratiques douteuses des banques
canadiennes ne manquera pas de candidats
prêts à témoigner à visage à découvert
plusieurs employés sous pression tout
simplement décidé de démissionner plutôt
de continuer à tromper leurs clients un
ancien planificateur financier à la
banque de montréal qui a quitté son
emploi il ya deux mois relate est
reparti après avoir eu une crise de
panique dans le bureau de sa
gestionnaire
celle ci menaçait de nuire à sa carrière
parce qu'il n'avait pas atteint les
objectifs de vente et soutient que sa
gestionnaire lui à une fois conseillé de
ne pas dire à ses clients qui voulaient
investir 40 mille dollars que les
marchés étaient en baisse parce que
placer leur argent dans un certificat de
placement garanti ne profiterait pas
autant à la succursale mois qu il ya un
conseiller michel nadeau de l'institut
sur la gouvernance d'organisations
privées et publiques au canada ce qui
est un amour la loyauté et en même temps
qu'elle et huit souffrent conseil et il
te prend 1,4 et avec une banque une
caisse populaire mais en 2003 c'est donc
toujours comparer et en attendant le
front commun offre pjd conseiller du
secret auquel elle travaille vraiment
pour nous l'enquète doit débuter le mois
prochain
un reportage de radio canada
international